cet appareil constitué par un anneau qui
comprend un relevant qui est déroulé et
accroché à un arbre survivant permet la
rotation du poulet qui va être grillé au
moyen d'un feu de braise ou un feu de
bois
cette année on peut se dérouler jusqu'à
une longueur de 3 mètres et l'appareil
est d'une grande simplicité terminée par
une broche qu'il faut supporter
n'importe quel village
c'est à paris était vraiment économie
qui ne comporte aucun moteur est
uniquement constituée d'un ruban la
cabine de bain individuelle et portative
fera sans aucun doute des adeptes sur
les plages
on peut sourire n'est pas trop la roue
de secours passe en torrent de dévier
heures en cas de choc brutal
voilà l'invention de monsieur jacques
gérin qui assure-t-il est capable de
vous sauver la vie
disposés à l'avant en guise de pare
chocs elle se met en mouvement sur
l'obstacle et en la dédiant empêche la
voiture d'accentuer la violence de la
collision
bonne idée
prague vient de mettre quoi ce curieux
engin biplace comprenant à la fois le
confort de l'auto et la maniabilité de
la moto2 petit nouveau mobile et bien
sûr une certaine stabilité
cette auto moto on peut dépasser la
vitesse de 120 km heure